H-A-N-S Hans Bindestrich Dietrich Dora Ida Emile Theodor Richard Ida César Heinrich
Dietrich, Hans Dietrich ist mein Vornam und mein Nachname ist Fischer
Dietrich D-I-E-C-R-I-T-I-E Theodor Richard Ida César Heinrich
Ida C-H
C-H, genau
Ich habe noch nicht getroffen
Und Nachname bitte?
Fischer
Ida Siegfried César Heinrich Emile Richard
F-I-S-C-H-E-R
Okay
C-H, kenne ich nicht
C-H, genau
C-H César
Jawohl
Okay
Herr Fischer, freut mich, wie alt sind Sie?
Mein, ich bin 42 Jahre alt
Jawohl
Und wissen Sie aktuell, wie groß Sie sind und wie viel Sie wiegen?
Ich bin 1,75 Meter groß und wiege 88 Kilo
Okay
Herr Fischer, was kann ich für Sie tun? Was für Beschwerden haben Sie?
Ich habe akute, linkstorakale Schmerzen, die von vorne nach hinten ausstrahlen
und seit heute Morgen
Insbesondere wenn ich atme, habe ich auch Schmerzen
Also wenn ich tiefer einatme, nehmen die Schmerzen zu
Okay
Wie stark ist die Schmerzen aus einer Schmerzkala von 0 bis 10?
Wobei null kann ich mehr sind, zerstere ich mehr sind, in der ich nicht bin
Ja, also wenn ich tiefer einatme und wuste, dann ist es 7, würde ich sagen, von 10
Sie haben schon gesagt, von hinten dann vorne ausstrahlen
Und kann ich jetzt nicht sagen, das ist von vorne nach hinten, nach vorne, die ganze Seite
Okay, und wie ist die andere Körpertage?
Nein, das ist nur in meinem linken Brustkopf
Linken Brustkopf, okay
Beschreiben Sie bitte diese Schmerzen, sind diese Schmerzen in Stechen, Drucken oder?
Ich würde sagen Stechen durchmerzen
Stechen durchmerzen
Wie ein Messerstisch
Okay, verstehe
Herr Fischer, es ist eine Notfallstation, ich muss dieses Gespräch unterbrechen
und sofort für Sie eine Röntgen Torax veranlasen und EKG schreiben
und ihren Vitalparameter überprüfen, okay?
Okay
Mhm
Okay, Herr Fischer
Sie haben schon gesagt, linken Torax, Schmerzen haben
Und sind Sie übel?
Hm?
Sind Sie übel?
Nicht sind Sie, sondern ist in Übeln, nein, in Übeln hab ich nicht
Und keine Erbrochen?
Ich habe nicht erwochen
Mhm, gut
Haben Sie Husten, Ausfuhr, Fieber?
Nein, hab ich nicht
Hm, okay
Hm, haben Sie eine Idee, wieso hatten Sie diese Schmerzen?
Nicht hatte, ich habe die immer noch, aber kann ich mir nicht vorstellen
Mhm
Weiß ich nicht
Sind Sie...
Ich bin heute morgen aufgewacht, heute morgen aufgewacht, aufgewacht
und beim Aufstehen im Bett hatte ich plötzlich diese Schmerzen gehabt
Okay
Herr Fischer, Sie sind aufgewacht, was ich habe
Nein, nein
Okay, okay, das ist auch nicht so, dass Sie aufgewacht haben
Nein, auch nicht
Haben Sie die Schmerzen?
Nein, habe ich auch nicht
Okay, versteh
Ich hab das nicht gemacht
Ja, ich nehme seit 2 Jahren Medikamente ein wegen der Bluthochdruck-Exanktion
Okay
Den hatte ich gemessen heute Morgen und heute Nachmittag
war normal gewesen
normal
war nicht auffällig
Okay, gut, und was nehmen Sie dagegen?
Da nehme ich täglich Ramiepril 10 mg ein, morgens
Okay, versteh
Herr Fischer, Sie haben schon gesagt, kein Fieber
und kein Husten-Schütterl für Frost vielleicht, oder?
Nein, auch nicht
Wie ist Ihre Appetit?
Normal
Haben Sie in letzter Zeit ab oder zu genommen?
Nein, nicht besonders, also etwa gleich
gleichgewichtig
Okay, Sie sind 80, viel und 1,75 m
Ja
Nicht so dünn
Okay
Leider Sie an früher, chronische Lungen in der Erkrankung?
An Lungen Erkrankungen? Nein, habe ich keine Erkrankungen
Ich leide nicht da drunter
Okay, verstehe
Wie schlafen Sie gut?
Theoretisch schon, ja
Haben Sie keine Sturrgangprobleme?
Auch Leider Sie an keine Run-Urin-Probleme?
Nein, Wasserlassen-Probleme habe ich auch nicht
Sturrgangprobleme habe ich auch nicht
Was ich dazu sagen kann, ist, dass dieser Schmerz atemabhängig ist
Wenn ich tief einatme, sticht es noch mehr rein
Okay, verstehe
Sie haben aber keine Brustschmerzen, oder?
Also ich habe Brustschmerzen, der ganze Brustkopf tut mir weh
Okay, aber keine Ausstrahlen, beispielsweise unter Kiffer, Arm oder?
Nein, Arm tut es nicht ausstrahlen, nein
Okay, aber Sie haben auch kalt, ich weiß?
Nein, habe ich nicht
Leider Sie an Angst?
Ich mache mir schon Gedanken
Man liest ja, wenn man ein Linkstorrack Schmerzen hat, ob man mit einem Herz ein Problem hat
Deswegen habe ich schon ein bisschen Bedenken, ja
Okay, danke schön
Also, wie es heute Morgen hat sich da keine Probleme
Wir haben schon ein bisschen ein Longer Problem
Wir haben schon ein bisschen ein Röntgen-Torrack, bei Ihnen durchefort, oder?
Nein, die Longer Aufnahme kann ich mich nicht erinnern
Interessant, okay, verstehe
Sie haben ein Torrack Schmerzen, tief alt mit einem Herz
Und gibt es etwas, was dieses Schmerzen für Lindert, Lindert oder Herzstark?
Ja, ich habe heute Morgen einen Improfen eingenommen, heute Mittag
Und das hat die 600 Milligramm, das hat die Schmerzen ein bisschen gelindert
Okay, und für Herzstark gibt es etwas, was dieses Schmerzen für Herzstark?
Verstärkt, bei komischer Bewegung, wenn ich mir, wenn ich jetzt nach links, nach hinten schaue,
beim Autofahren, zum Beispiel, verstecke den Schmerz
Ja, mein Brustkopf ist nicht richtig bewegend
Okay, haben Sie auch Nackensteifigkeit?
Nackensteifigkeit? Nein, ein bisschen, ja, aber nicht so wirklich, ich kann nicht gut bewegen
Okay, ja, in nächstes Zeit haben Sie etwas schwieriger Aufgenomen
Ich habe etwas getragen, etwas schweres, nicht, dass ich mich erinnern kann
Okay, verstehe
Sie leiden herfischen Bluthochdruck, sonst noch andere Erkrankungen?
Also sonst nämlich keine regelmäßige Medikamente einnehmen
Und keine Krankungen?
Nicht, dass ich jetzt...
Altezukei, Chytryzum, Ubeonterfunktion?
Nein, habe ich nicht
Okay, Medikamente nur Ramyprin?
Genau
Sind Sie allergisch gegen Netfass?
Ja, gegen Penicillin
Wie reagieren Sie darauf?
Also ich habe es jahrelang nicht genommen, damals, wo ich jung war, operiert worden war, hat man jetzt Penicillin gegeben
und dann haben die mir gesagt, dass ich schlechtartig geatmet hätte
Ich habe mich nicht mehr erinnern, da war ich zehn Jahre alt
Okay
Damals hatten Sie in Tassi Station behandelt?
Nein, ich wurde operiert an meinen Mandeln
Nein, ich verstehe aber, wegen dieser Penicillin, ist das allergische Schock oder flacktische Schock?
Ich weiß es nicht, ich war zehn Jahre alt, seitdem darf ich nicht mehr...
Ich war zehn Jahre alt und wurde operiert, damals haben die Antibüne gegeben,
und da habe ich dann halt reagiert mit Atemnot, sagen die meine Eltern
und seitdem darf ich nicht mehr Penicillin einnehmen
Okay, aber mussten Sie damals in Krankenhaus...
Ich war ja operiert worden, wegen dieser Atmen
Ich war ja in Krankenhaus, ich weiß es nicht
Die OP war damals in Krankenhaus gewesen
Danke, nachdem zu Hause ging
Und sonst noch etwas, haben Sie andere Medikamente, allergie, Unfertiglichkeiten?
Unverträglichkeit, ja, wenn ich mal die Glyphenac nehme, dann vertrage ich den nicht
Wie äußert sich diese Glyphenac-Unfertiglichkeit?
Ja, ich kriege dann Magenschmerzen und Brennen mit aufstoßen
und dann kommt die Säure so ein bisschen nach oben, sozusagen
in den Speiseröhre
Herr Fischer, haben Sie keine Magenprobleme, oder? Normalerweise
Normalerweise nicht, so wenn ich diese Medikamente ein paar Tage nehme
und damals, da kriege ich den nicht mehr ein
Ich nehme nur Ibuprofen ein, mit Magenschutz-Tablette, damit geht es gut
Okay, Sie wurden nur eine Magenmander entfangen
Sonst noch etwas? Nicht, dass ich mich erinnere
Okay, rachen Sie? Ja
Wie viel Zigarette pro Tag? So eine Packung, eine Packung pro Tag
Schon, ja
Seit wann? Oh je, das ist bestimmt seit 20 Jahren
20 Jahren, es ist aber zu viel
Haben Sie versucht, mit dem Rachen anzuhören?
Ja, aber ist die Arbeit, wo ich arbeite, da ist ein bisschen Stress
und dass die Arbeit, wo ich mich ablenken kann
Ja, ich verstehe Ihre Probleme, aber
ich danke Sie wegen vieler dieser Rachen, Ihren Problemursachen
Ah, weiß ich nicht
Weil Sie möchten, wir sind immer da
Weil Sie möchten mit dem Rachen auszuhören, wir sind immer da Herr Fischer
Okay, danke
Zielenken Sie Alkohol? Ja
Wie viel und was zielenken Sie?
Ja, so eine, ungefähr kann man sagen, eine Flasche Bier am Abend
trinke ich immer, nach dem Feierabend
vor dem Fernseher trinke ich eine Flasche Bier, kann man sagen
Seit wann? Seit wann? Oh je, seitdem ich 16 Jahre alt bin
aber nicht jeden Tag, seit jeden Tag vielleicht
seit 15 Jahren vielleicht, seitdem ich dort arbeite
Okay, nehmen Sie bitte diese nächste Frage nicht persönlich
es ist eine mutinmedische Frage
Nehmen Sie Drogen?
Drogen, nein, ich nehme keine Drogen ein
Okay, leben Ihre Eltern noch? Ja
Sind sie gesund?
Ja, so ein bisschen schon, aber
der Vater hatte mal einen Herzinfarkt gehabt, hat einen Stempel bekommen
vor 10 Jahren
und der leitet an Bluthochdruckerkrankungen wie ich auch
und meine Mutter, die ist zuckerkrankt, nimmt Medikamente dafür ein
seit 15 Jahren
und sie wurde an der Schildrüse operiert, mindestens 20 Jahre her oder länger
weiß ich nicht
Ihre Mutter leidet an Altezucker
und das weiß ich nicht, die nimmt die Zuckermedikamente
glaube ich seit 10 oder 15 Jahren her
auch Inselin geschickt wird es nicht? Nein, da wird kein Inselin geschickt, sondern nimmt Medikamente ein
ich weiß nicht wie alt ist Ihre Mutter und Vater?
Ja, mein Vater ist 65 Jahre, meine Mutter ist 60
und Ihre Familienmitglieder haben Ihre Familienmitglieder eine lunge Erkrankung?
Nicht, dass ich wüsste
und Ihre Mutter ist in der Schildrüse operiert?
Ja
Welche Krankheiten wissen Sie? Eine Kropstruma?
Nein, ich weiß nicht, ich weiß nur, dass die Schildrüse komplett entfernt wurde
Und Sie sind ein Einzelkind?
Ich habe noch einen Bruder
Ist er gesund?
Ja, nicht, dass ich wüsste, ich denke, er ist gesund
Super
Was machen Sie beruflich?
Ich bin Disponent bei einer großen Logistikfirma
Disponent
Disponent, dass die Fracht von A nach B geht, sozusagen, oder die Lkw ist und so weiter
Okay, ja, fahren Sie mit dem Atom?
Ich bin ein Büro und organisiere, dass die Lkw ich disponiere, ich organisiere, dass die Fracht, also diese Güter von A nach B püglich ankommt
Okay
Und müssen Sie immer sitzen am Computer, oder?
Ich sitze sehr viel, das stimmt
Haben Sie Stress in der Arbeit und im Lebens?
Ja, das ist sehr fessig
Sie sind verheiratet?
Ja, ich bin verheiratet
Wollen Sie mit Ihrem Frauen zusammen?
Ja, mit meiner Frau und zwei Kindern wollen ich zusammen, ja
Sind Ihre Kinder gesund?
Ja, die sind Gott sei Dank gewohnt
Gesund, super
Sind Sie vollständig?
Wie ging die Kinderkrankheit und die Corona?
Corona bin ich nicht geimpft, da hatte ich die Erkrankung am Anfang, danach würde ich nicht mehr gehen oder wollte ich auch nicht mehr
Und die anderen Impfungen, was man so Kindheit hat, die habe ich alle gehabt, also vollständig
Und sind Sie ins Ausland gewesen?
In nächstes, seit ich meine, in nächstes sechs Monate
In den letzten Sommer war ich auf Mallorca
Mallorca, nächstes Sommer
Wie viele Monate?
Ungefähr sechs Monate bis hier
Haben Sie damals keine Entzündung Erkrankungen?
Oder nee, weil ich topfit, hat das gemacht, es war eine schöne Urlaub
Okay, super
Und selbst Sie regelmäßig Sport?
Nee, habe ich keine Zeit dazu
Möchten wir etwas zu üben, Herr Fischer, ich habe für Sie alle wichtige Fragen gesteckt
Okay, ja wie geht es denn weiter, was habe ich denn?
Haben Sie schon das Röntgen und RKG gesehen? Können Sie mir was dazu sagen?
Ja Herr Fischer, ich denke Sie haben eine
Ich denke Lungen, Herr Fischer, aber ich bin mir nicht sicher
Okay, wie geht es weiter?
Ja, ich brauche etwas, ich brauche drei verschiedene Untersuchungen, körperliche Untersuchungen
Zuerst natürlich gutbildt und vielleicht eine Torax-Tomography durchveranlassen
Okay, okay, gut
Okay, danke, ich hoffe, dass ich nichts habe, ich habe ein bisschen Bedenken
Ja okay, machen Sie sich keine Sorge, Sie sind in guter Enden, wir sind eine Professionale
Okay, danke schön
Danke schön, haben Kollegen oder Kolleginnen noch andere Fragen?
Darf ich fragen?
Ist Ihnen besonders auf der betroffenen Bereich, irgendwelche Hautausschläge aufgefallen?
Nein, das ist nicht aufgefallen, die Haut ist normal
Haben Sie Taubhalsgefühl oder Krimaren?
Taubhalsgefühl habe ich auch nicht, nein, Klippel noch nicht
Danke
Darf ich fragen?
Ja
Haben Sie Herzraten, Herzstolpen oder Herzklopfen bemerkt?
Nein, die wollte nicht
Wie war Blutdruck?
Blutdruck war normal, ich hatte heute Morgen und heute Mittag zu Hause gemessen
mit dem Gerät, das ich habe, das war 120 zu 80 und einmal war 130 zu 80
Danke schön
Darf ich Ihnen ein paar Vorstellungen?
Ja
Drei Frage Maximum, haben Sie in letzter Zeit eine Virusinfektion gehabt?
Ich hatte eine Erkältung, ich denke, das war eine Virusinfektion
Ich hatte eine Erkältung vor vier Wochen, ne acht Wochen, schon länger her
Aber das war ganz normale Erkältung, wie man immer hatte, wie ich das sieht
Ich hatte eine Erkältung, die ich mal habe, alle paar Jahre
und es war jetzt schon nach drei Tagen, ging es mir gut
Danke
Ich hatte keine Hustenprobleme oder irgendwie
Ein paar hat gesagt, eine, warum ein paar?
Was denn?
Legen hat gesagt, dass er ein paar Fragen stellen möchte
Aber gleich nur ein paar, das sind zwei Stück
Das ist eine Frage
Gut
Noch eine Frage, Kollegen
Könnten wir als Gechübde anfangen?
Ich versuche
Sind Sie schon gestürzt, haben Sie sich verletzt?
Eine Frage, aber schon beantwortet
Bitte schön
Sehr geehrte Herr Oberass, ich habe einen neuen Patientin, den ich Ihnen vorstellen möchte
Darf ich?
Ja bitte, schießen Sie los
Es geht um Herr Thomas Dietrich Fischer
Herr Hans Dietrich Fischer
Er ist 42 Jahre alt, 1,75 m groß und 88 kg
Er stammelt bei uns
Seit heute Morgen, plötzlich bestehende
Laufen plötzlich bestehende
Tiefe einatmen, verstärkte
Sie haben einen Link-Site, der Sie nicht mehr verletzt
Das war jetzt ein bisschen sehr viel
Können Sie die in paar Sätze sagen?
Nicht alles in einem, das, das, das
Er hat das, er hat das
Sie sind total recht
Herr Fischer, ich stelle bei uns
Heute Morgen, bestehende
Stärke Torakar GIFO
Die sind...
Welche Seite?
Heute Morgen
Linkseite
Die sind...
Wir...
Wir haben...
Und für die...
Torakar...
Toraks
Nein...
Auf latinisch vorne ist was?
Vorne, latinisch...
Anterrier
Oder...
Ventral
Ja, ja, ventral
Momentan nach Dorsal oder Dorsal nach Ventral
Ausstrahlung des Schmerzes
Ja, die Schmerzen strahlen vorne nach...
vorne nach...
hinter oder hinter...
nach vorne ausstrahlen
Also zäkulär, würde man sagen
Zäkulär Schmerzen von Dorsal nach Ventral oder Ventral nach Dorsal
Die Schmerzen sind in der Intensität
Wir haben tiefer Inspiration
Sieben von zählen auf der NRS
Die Schmerzen würden...
Die Schmerzen sein
Stechen der Schmerzen
Die...
Okay
Haben Sie gefragt, bei welcher Situation es zunimmt
oder...
Ja, bei Bewegung
haben sich diese Schmerzen verstärkt
Bei welcher Bewegung?
Ja, recht seit...
Rotation
Bei Rotationsbewegung, ja
Bei Rotationsbewegung
Verstärkt
Und auch noch bei anderen Situationen?
Noch an der Situation verstärkt
Bewegung
Bewegung und...
zum Beispiel haben Sie gefragt, ob das atemabhängig ist
Ja, ich habe schon gesagt
tiefer atmen, tiefer Inspiration
Bei tiefer Inspiration
Verstärkt
Noch mal bitte, einen Satz
Tiefer Atmen hat die Schmerzen verstärkt
A-B-Sicht
Ein tiefer Einatmung oder tiefer Atmung
verstärkt die Schmerzen, okay?
Okay
Die...
Er hat...
Den Patent, habe er vor vier Wochen
leichte Erkärtung gehabt
Fragen nach Fibar
Husten, Auswurf
Nacken, Stärkigkeit
Wurstschmerzen oder
Tora Kargi, Herzproblemen
wurden verleicht
Aktuell oder damals, wo er Erkältung hatte?
Hab ich nicht verstanden? Nein, aktuell
Also, weil Sie gesagt haben, vor vier Wochen
hat er Erkältung gehabt
Drei Tage, danach hatte er wieder...
Oder wie kann man sonst sagen, hatte er sich erholt
hatte er sich erholt
Erholt, ja, danke schön
Die wirgeltete Anamnesie ist...
Aber Sie haben gesagt, dass er keine Tora Kargi haben würde
aber der hat einen Schmerz, der zirkulär ist
also ist doch eine Tora Kargi da
Nein, aber...
Vor vier Wochen
Also vor vier Wochen, ja
Gerade habe er natürlich...
wegen dieser Stärkigkeit...
Ich denke, dass er hier kommt
Okay
Ich habe...
wegen dieser Schmerz
heute E-Buffer-Profen
600 Milligramm, ein Mal
eingenommen
dass er ein bisschen Linderung gebraucht hat
Ja, das habe eine Linderung gebracht
oder so zum Beispiel
Anfragerkranken sein Diffognen bekannt
Artillery-Ipertoni
seit...
... zwei Jahren
... zwei Jahre
... ein Mal
zum Beispiel, ein Mal 10 Milligramm
... ein Mal, das kann zum Schluss einnehmen
Nicht vergessen
Er sei allergisch gegen Penicillin
die äußere sich...
... mit Dispno
Mit Dispno
Bitte
Die äußere sich mit Dispno
Ja, die äußere sich mit Dispno
Okay
Und er habe auch die Lofenach-Unfallträglichkeit
Keiten, die äußere sich mit
Magni Schmerzen
Magni Schmerzen, Gastragi
und...
... und Ruckflux
Aufstößen
Reflex oder Ruflux?
Ruflux, aufstößen
Ruflux
Reflex, genau
Er wurde...
... zu standtag nach Tonsilektimi mit
... 10 Jahre alt
Er wurde damals am...
... die...
... Penicillin allergie...
... erlipte
Er habe Penicillin allergie erlipte
Erlipte oder durchgemacht, können wir auch sagen
Okay
Oder...
... durchgemacht, würde ich mal erst sagen
Er hat eine...
... Penicillin allergie durchgemacht
Penicillin allergie
Wenn man das so formuliert
Ruflux, er habe...
Oder er hat auf Penicillin allergie reagiert, kann man auch sagen
... damals
Er habe Penicillin allergie reagiert
Reaktionen gehabt oder reagiert
Auf Penicillin allergie reagiert, kann man auch sagen
Gibt es hier Möglichkeiten?
Er habe seit 20 Jahren ein Schachtel Zigaretin pro Tag geraucht
Das heißt...
... das heißt, 25-Jährige Nikotin-Abosos
Er trinke jeden Tag...
... fast jeden Tag ein Flasche Bia abends
Seit 15 oder 16 Jahren angefangen habe
Robin Konsumurdum fernlein
Die Familienanalyse ergab
Myocardinfarktus
Baydem Fata
Deswegen wurde bei ihm mitgestellt behandelt
Und er leider an auch Bluthochturuk
Artillery Portoni
Und...
... die Schildrüse und die Schildrüse
... beide sind gut
Sie...
... sie wurden...
Was für Schildrüse und Probleme hat sie gehabt?
Ja, sie wurden operiert
Sie wurden operiert an der Schildrüse
Was heißt das?
...
... Trodektomi?
Ja, genau
Er sei...
... ein Bruder...
... er...
... er geht uns sein
Er sei gesund
Er sei...
... disponent
... in einer Logistikfirma
Er hatte viel Stress in der Arbeit und im Leben
Er...
... hat es im Leben nicht gesagt
... aber er hat es...
... in der Arbeit
Er ist verheiratet
Und er ist mit seinem Familien zusammen
Er ist in der Arbeit
Aber keine Komplik geimpft.
Als Auslandreisen an Amnesie wurden fernleinert,
als Betriebe kein Sport,
Traum und Fälle zu tun wurden fernleinert.
Die Anamnesterche Angabe der Doitun Amesin auf Pynomotoraxin.
Differenzial Diagnostisch, Komunaba,
Agse, Akute Coronar Sendrom,
Reflexkrankheit, vielleicht habe ich aber keine Probleme.
Muskul, Mijagi, vieler Mijagi.
Das kann auch sein zum Beispiel, wenn das Atemabhängig ist.
Wenn jemand atmet und es eratmet ein, tief ein und aus,
das macht es, bewegt sich Torax, richtig?
Ja.
Wie ist der Torax aufgebaut?
Prioritis.
Ja, könnte sein.
Der Torax selber, die Wand, Torax Wand,
ist aufgebaut mit, was haben Sie vorhin gesagt, Muskeln?
Muskeln und ...
Plerasie, Plerasie, Plerasie.
Das ist internistisch.
Denken Sie mal ein bisschen anders.
Rippen, Rippen kommt?
Ja, genau.
Es gibt auch Rippen zum Beispiel.
Rippen?
Genau.
Also wenn der nicht gestürzt ist,
denke ich nicht, dass er ein Rippenfaktor hat.
Stimmt, kann man so sagen.
Aber was kann es sonst sein?
Wenn sich die Rippen bewegen, die Rippen arbeiten,
wenn man Schmerzen hat und die Rippen arbeiten,
und wenn ich nicht atme oder flach atme,
habe ich keine Schmerzen.
Was kann man haben?
Zum Beispiel einige Sachen.
Zum Beispiel, man nennt es einmal intercostal myotalgie,
die man schon hat.
Aber für ja keine Probleme.
Ja, keine intercostal ...
... aufgestanden, oder die Rippengelenke,
die Gelenke an den Rippen, die können blockieren.
Wenn es eine plötzliche Blockade an den Rippen haben,
dann haben die diese ähnliche Symptomatik wie bei einem,
was man alles mit links zu einer kalten Schmerzen hat,
sozusagen.
Was kann man noch haben?
Jemand hat gefragt ...
... eine Pyloresi gesagt.
Zum Beispiel, man könnte auch Bläschen haben.
Man kann auch nur ...
... Pepistoster, also ...
Ja, Pepistoster.
Genau, könnte man theoretisch auch haben.
Ich habe nicht gefragt,
jedenfalls halt veränden können.
Ja, aber es hat ein Kollege gefragt in der Gruppe.
Und gesagt, die Bläschen hat er nicht.
Okay.
So, sagen wir mal ...
Sie denken jetzt an TORAX oder irgendetwas X.
Was geht es jetzt voran?
Was machen Sie schon untersuchen, dass Sie das ausschließen können?
Ja, ich habe schon Röntgen TORAX durchgeführt.
Durchgeführt, okay?
Ja, gegebenenfalls vielleicht eine Zone TORAX,
vielleicht ein bisschen argus auszuschließen.
Ja, auszuschieben.
Ja, aber auch Kaman TORAX-SETIL.
Haben Sie auch ...
... weil Sie vorhin gesagt haben, es könnte auch ein New York-Cardinfarkt sein?
Ja, EKG, ja.
Durchgeführt, okay.
Ich habe schon ...
... durchgeführt.
Okay, noch nicht drauf geguckt.
Und Laborparameter, was denken Sie,
was man abnehmen sollte, mindestens?
Ja.
Also nicht alle Laborparameter sind wichtig, aber ...
Ja, wenn eine ...
... Pneumotax, Müslüme vielleicht eine Direnaio, deswegen wir müssen ...
... ein Blutbild ...
... innere, Quick-Werte ...
... ja Müslüme ja checken, auch Entzündung ausschließen,
... BESK ...
... vielleicht ...
... ja, wir haben jetzt die Institutionen,
... Leberwerte, Nürnmerte ...
... ich bin nicht sicher ...
Wenn Sie das Wichtigste von den ganzen, wo wir schnell reagieren müssen,
wäre was?
Einer von den wichtigen?
Ja, Akutus Coronar Syndrome,
... was würden Sie dafür Labor abnehmen,
für Akutus Coronar Syndrome?
Ja, das wäre auch wichtig,
... das ist auch eine Differenz der Diagnostik.
Ja, wenn ...
... wenn denke ich,
... die Diagnostik ist eine Diagnostik.
Ja, genau, also das ist dann eine Sekundärdiagnostik.
Okay, sagen wir mal, wir kommen jetzt drauf,
... Röhrung,
... auch ...
... Torax in 2 Ebenen,
sind alle unaufwählig, keine Erzündungsparameter.
Haben wir dann jetzt alles ausgeschlossen oder wie gehen wir voran?
Ja, city is Torax.
Ja, theoretisch würde man erst mal aus, erst mal gründlich untersuchen.
Je nach Untersuchung können wir dann weitere Untersuchungen weiter einleiten.
Ja, aber habe ich Tag geschmessen.
Deswegen muss man dann nicht mehr city Torax veranlassen.
Kann man machen.
Wenn man irgend eine, was wollen Sie da sehen, wenn Sie DDR negativ sind,
wenn Sie wahrscheinlich mit Kontrastmittel kann man sehen, ob die...
Ob du Blaksynografie meinst du? Nein?
Nein.
Also ich will jetzt mit dieser Anamnese, was Sie jetzt haben,
was wir bis heute bis jetzt haben, haben wir also mehrere Erkrankungen gesagt.
Wir haben von Württengel gesprochen, wir haben Zoster erkrankt, also Kürtelrose
erkrankt gesprochen, Präumatorax gesprochen.
Also wenn Präumatorax ist es ja anscheinend nicht, weil die Röntgen auch nahmen normal aussehen.
Also, wir denken.
Er hat keine Bläschen an der Haut, also Hautveränderung hat sie nichts.
Also kann man auch Kürtelrose ausschließen, erst mal.
Kann nur sein, aber vielleicht ist es noch ein Ausbruch.
Wir wissen das noch nicht.
Dann, was haben wir gesagt, Herz im Trakt, EKG ist normal, Troponin und CKMB und so weiter,
ist alles normal, kann man das ausschließen?
Nein, man sollte wieder 36 Stunden wieder EKG und diese Parameter wiederholen.
Wiederholen.
Nach meines Wissens, ich bin kein Kardiologe, nach meines Wissens nach 4 Stunden.
Zumindest in meiner Zeit war es so.
Okay.
Dann, okay, das ist in noch Fragezeichen.
Brauchen wir dafür einen CT, um einen Corona, also.
Ein Geobrüttel?
Genau, dafür brauchen wir eigentlich aber nicht einen CT, weil Sie gesagt haben, wir brauchen einen CT vielleicht.
Mhm.
Wozu brauchen Sie einen CT?
Das wollte ich fragen.
Also wenn zum Beispiel kein Präumatorax ist im Röntgen, sieht man, dass es keine Luftzeichen sind.
Und so hat das, ich versuche laut zu denken, das Problem zu lösen.
Aber, also nehmen wir aber an, wir machen eine körperliche Untersuchung.
Mhm.
Eine körperliche Untersuchung hat ja eine Torax-Komposition Schmerz zum Beispiel.
Auf der linken Seite, wenn ich den Torax komprimiere, hat er Schmerz.
Wenn ich Paravert-Tabral an der Wirbelsäule rechts komprimiere, kein Schmerz an den Rippen.
Aber links hat er Schmerz.
Also würde man erst als erstes denken, dass er interkostal neural geht.
Das ist ein sehr generelles Wort.
Oder wenn es Atema bringe, würde ich sagen, dass es eine Kostavert-Tabral-Lokate ist.
Dass dieser Gelenk sozusagen von den Rippen entweder gereizt, entzündet oder blockiert ist.
Und das kann die Rippen gehen von hinten bis nach vorne, bis nach vorne zum Herzregion ausstrahlen.
Aber trotzdem sollte man erste Versuchungen machen, dann weitere Diagnostik eventuell durchführen.
Ja, aber welche Ursache diese interkostal neural geht?
Die Lokate von Gelenken an der Wirbelsäule, Gelenke plötzlich blockieren, tut es plötzlich weh.
Warum? Weiß keiner.
Kalte Luft oder kalte Ritter?
Der hat ja gesagt, das muss nicht sein. Kann sein, weiß man manchmal nicht.
Der hat sich falsch bewegt.
Tennis-Cypillen vielleicht?
Das muss nicht sein. Er kann sogar ein sportlicher Mensch sein, der sehr gesund lebt.
Er kann plötzlich eine Blockade eines Halswirbelkörpers kommen.
Oder eine Akkudulumbago. Warum entsteht eine Akkudulumbago?
Muss ein kalter Wetter sein? Muss er schwer tragen?
Muss er? Nein. Das kann plötzlich beim Aufstehen.
Ich wollte nur die Wäsche hochheben, die war leicht.
Ich wollte nur einen Kuli auf dem Boden, einen Kugelschreiber vom Boden, eben zack, habe ich Schmerzen.
Das kommt manchmal.
Interessant.
Ich habe eine Utopäde und deswegen habe ich heute einen orthophitischen Fall vorgestellt.
Mit dem Herzgeschichten und so weiter, dass man auch die anderen Sachen spricht.
Man kann auch zum Beispiel sagen, Akut, ich kann natürlich auch sein,
das akute Facetten-Syndrom der Brustwirbelkörper.
Kann auch sein, wenn es linksseitig ist.
Das kann auch linksseitig ausstrahlen sozusagen.
Gleich das der Atom, kann es dann auch, Bandscheinvorfall an der Brustwirbelsäule ist selten.
Nicht viel selten, nicht so, aber kann es auch sein.
Auch eine Differenzialdiagnose.
Interessant.
Ja, das ist sehr, ich denke persönlich, das ist auch sehr oft,
viele Leute, die haben eher entweder intercostale Neuralgie
oder Blutkarte der Rippengelenke atemabhängig.
Das ist nicht immer, aber öfters mit Rippenshatte zu tun.
Viele gehen immer zur Krankenhaus, ich finde es auch richtig,
weil Rippenschmerzen kann warten bis zum nächsten Tag,
aber wenn es doch eine akute Coronasyndrom ist, der nicht warten.
Deswegen lieber einmal zur Krankenhaus, mehr gehen und ausschließen, als nicht.
Aber die meisten haben dann keine Herzinfarkt, aber hätte sein können.
Und die Zerattherapie, nicht die Antirheumatik und Wärmeanwendungen auch?
Genau, Wärmeanwendungen, um die Muskulatur weichzumachen.
Ja, Miorerelexan.
Ja, Miorerelexan kann man zusätzlich geben,
aber Wärme ist auch eine Muskelentspannung.
Zweitens, orthopedische Hauptmedikament ist Antirheumatik,
also Medikamentir, ZIR.
Zusätzlich kann man noch weitere Stärke,
andere Analgetiker dazugeben, wie Nowalgin, wie Theridin,
oder Tramal oder Morchi zum Beispiel.
Und diese Patiente sollte vielleicht acht, sechs Stunden bei uns bleiben, danach?
Genau, er kann in der Notfallanwaltschaft warten bis nach sechs bis acht Stunden.
Wenn man die Laborkontrolle noch macht, dann kann man sicher gehen,
okay, das wird es nicht sein.
Weil manchmal kann man auch ein Herzinfarkt bekommen
und gleichzeitig eine Blockade der Webelsäule haben.
Aber man kann nicht sagen, das ist eine Blockade, tschüss.
Sondern man würde trotzdem Laborwerte noch abwarten,
weil dahinter kann was anderes noch sein.
Ja, ich denke diese Fall, unsere Leben haben wir sehr oft getroffen.
Wir sind nicht, aber nicht so stark.
Genau.
Aber ennische, wegen Kälte was war da?
Ja, das kann nur nicht sein, kann, Kälte kann sein.
Man hätte ein Tag vorher vielleicht etwas schwerer Arbeit gemacht,
aber muss man nicht.
Man kann auch plötzlich auf einmal diese Schmerzen haben,
von nichts auf nichts.
Wir müssen Sportreiben.
Ich mache den meisten.
Tabletten, er nimmt zum Beispiel die Tablette ein.
Aber viele, nicht nur sie, sondern auch andere Kollegen,
vergessen dann und sagen dann, ja, er habe akkrilehypothoniert,
dagegen nehme er 10 mg mit ihm morgens.
Morgens was, morgens ein, zum Beispiel.
Das sind so Kleinigkeiten.
Aber es kommt daher, weil man viel üben muss.
Deswegen sage ich, Übung macht den Meister.
Immer wieder wiederholen, wiederholen.
Und versuchen die Sätze, Kalloplade,
Kallop auf Deutsch weiß ich nicht.
Und dass man die immer wieder wiederholt, dann kommt es schneller.
So zu sagen.
Wenn ich noch andere Fragen.
Wie bitte?
Je mehr schneller ich bin, desto mehr schlecht.
Desto mehr ich bin schlecht.
Das war falsch.
Weil sie überlegt haben.
Ich muss jetzt überlegen, nein, ich will richtig sprechen.
Da reden sie einfach so, da geht es besser.
Je schneller ich rede, desto mehr mache ich Fehler.
Zum Beispiel.
Wollten sie, glaube ich, sagen.
Aber ohne Denken kann man nicht sprechen.
Ja, genau.
Wenn man die Sätze, die man nicht mehr hat, denkt,
ich muss jetzt Pedal hoch und nächste Pedal runter.